the coronavirus threat is reaching
levels we have never seen in some areas
the u.s set a new single day record
yesterday with more than 136 thousand
new infections
and coronavirus hospitalizations have
hit an all-time high
of almost 62 000 that's more that we saw
when the pandemic began back in last
spring
think about that for a second in another
milestone texas has become the first
state with more than one
million cases janet chamblin is in el
paso that's one of the state's hardest
hit areas
janet good morning to you how bad is it
ah gail good morning to you it is bad
here health care workers are just
overwhelmed the number of people
hospitalized with covid
has doubled from earlier this fall at
the university of medical center there
are tents set up outside and on tuesday
we watched as a steady stream of
ambulances brought people on stretchers
into those tents it's the first stop for
covet patients
and there is a separate tent there set
up just for
infants and for children the medical
examiner has brought in mobile morgues
to handle bodies
and while the city's two-week lockdown
is scheduled to end today
the county judge has threatened to
extend it across the midwest cases are
also exploding a number of cities
desperately trying to get the surges
under control
wisconsin's governor has issued a new
stay-at-home advisory
and iowa's governor announced mask
requirements for the first time there
and get this
in north dakota health care workers who
have tested
positive for the virus but who are
asymptomatic
can return to work because they need
those people
so badly there is some positive news the
cdc has issued new guidance on masks
saying that masks now protect both
the wearer and other people that is a
change in guidance
and dr anthony fauci is saying that he
believes
that drug maker pfizer will get
emergency approval for its vaccine
by the end of the month tony guidance
only works if people are actually guided
by it we hope people listen janet thank
you very much